we have a great suggestion from aurelia  who commented on our youtube page maybe  you have a segment where you review the  latest movies shows and books oh  oralia i love this idea  what if we call it drew's reviews you  know we love to rhyme everything with my  name around here reviews no  that doesn't really work drew's reviews  is probably better but i along with all  of you can review new tv shows upcoming  movies instagram accounts so much stuff  in pop culture let's do this and we  actually worked up two graphics for this  new segment so we'd like to ask you  which one do you guys like better take  the poll because we'd love to get some  of your suggestions for what i should  review  and keep those suggestions coming  basically the power is in your hands  i'm excited thank you for the  suggestions let us know what you want  and we will deliver